-Guys, the election
is less than a month away.
Now, Joe Biden has a steady lead
over Donald Trump, nationally,
but Trump is polling better
with certain groups.
To break these numbers down,
it's time for a segment called
"Leaderboard 2020."
♪♪
Let's check out the first poll.
Joe Biden has a big lead
with black women,
but Trump is leading with
white women
who only know one black woman.
Next up, Trump is polling better
with people
who spread conspiracy theories
on Facebook.
Biden is leading with people
who only use the computer
at the library.
Next up, Biden is leading with
healthcare workers.
Trump is leading with people
who think taking
NyQuil and DayQuil at the
same time cancel each other out.
[ Laughter ]
Let's take a look
at another poll.
Trump is doing better
with the 1%.
Biden is leading with people
who remember when you could get
a gallon of milk for 1 cent.
Next up, this poll found
that Biden is leading with
people under 45, while Trump is
leading with people who
post their Google searches as
their Facebook status.
And, finally, Biden leads with
non-white voters,
but Trump leads with
white people
who have wooden kitchen signs
that say
"Dream big, eat bigger"
in cursive font.
That's all the time we have for
"Leaderboard 2020."